well they need the saints to lose some
games otherwise they're going to have to
do it the hard way and go on the road in
the wild card round they need to make up
ground two games over the next seven
weeks on the saints which is not easy
but maybe it will be easier if drew
brees is unable to play and look the the
the saints already had the game in hand
against the 49ers when drew brees exited
and
there's some
i don't know is it his shoulder is it
his rib what's really the injury the
team
officially says it's ribs
breeze says it's an accumulative thing
he's been limited in practice the past
couple of weeks with a shoulder problem
i mean it's all at the same time
where does the shoulder end and the ribs
begin rib cage goes all the way up right
dr florio says that's hey i didn't i i'm
not a doctor but i do know the rib cage
goes all the way up it does uh so you
know the bottom line is he he wasn't
able to go and we know how
drew brees is intense he's a competitor
he's never going to give an inch
he and and if he can't go he can't go uh
and jameis winston did and now they've
got to turn it around and get ready for
the falcons and and again drew was
already limited in practice
i don't know that he's going to be ready
for sunday's game uh and it's going to
create a fascinating discussion as the
week unfolds as to who the quarterback
will be but it was jameis winston for
now
and uh
chris uh here's let's let's hear from
sean payton and drew brees on uh
whatever the injury is to the
quarterback
you know he took a heavy shot in the
first half
um came in
uh as he came out in the second half he
felt
it was really impacting him you know so
i'm not you know specifically he'll get
he'll get an mri and x-ray his back felt
sore
as he tried to throw he just came up to
me and said hey i don't feel like it's
uh
i'm capable of
of playing and so quickly we made the
switch i i was not going to be able to
be effective
um it had nothing to do with pain it was
simply just what my body was
going to be able to do or not be able to
do
yeah
drew was not happy yeah that he was
unable to finish the game and to the
extent that anyone out there thinks so
he's not tough or he couldn't deal with
baloney you know they weren't going to
shoot up no he can't
whatever it is that's why i think some
people believe it's more than ribs
because dr needle as you like to call
him could make an appearance in the
locker room and numb the rib area
there's something that's preventing
or making it more difficult structurally
yeah to get his arm to do what it needs
to do to throw the football accurately
and with appropriate strength on a
regular basis come on i mean drew brees
they don't they don't make him any
tougher than drew brees i mean you know
you know sean payton said 15 years of
coaching the guy never heard him say i
can't go
so he when he said when he said that to
sean payton sean payton was probably
like oh okay i mean he you mean because
that doesn't come out of his mouth and
yeah i mean you're right mike it's you
know that's one of those things like uh
you hurt your shoulder this shoulder
capsule the ribs there i don't care how
much numbing you put when you throw it
you could feel things aren't right and
for a quarterback any injury in that rib
shoulder man when you have to raise your
arm to throw it and of course the torque
that you create to throw the ball and
have that flexion in your arm can create
incredible pain
i've only like pulled muscles in my ribs
through my years of playing a
quarterback and like was like whoa i
gotta take a few days off from throwing
football let alone having it beat up to
maybe the extent he has had it there so
we're gonna see like you said this has
been an issue and the saints are this is
where you know we just talked about the
bucks where we're like what day is it
the saints are hard too i mean that
wasn't good great football by them
yesterday it was there to be had for the
49ers i mean it really was the 49ers
messed it up there's no other way to say
it i mean their special teams were
horrible they let up a long kick return
when the saints couldn't do anything on
offense you know of course the muff
punts they go for it on like fourth and
one in the middle of the field can't get
that you know the saints were kind of
sleepwalking but the 49ers mistakes kind
of let them off the hook and they found
a way to win but it's just like the
saints are confusing that way they're
again they're another team where i go
they got this potential to be the best
team in the nfc but they have these
weeks where i just go yeah
they don't look great i don't get it and
that's where they're frustrating to me
and they're still holding on to first
place in the nfc south by a game plus
the tiebreaker over the tampa bay
buccaneers they've got the falcons this
weekend that is an intense rivalry the
falcons have a week to get ready for it
the falcons are better than the record
would suggest and here's the question
it's one thing to say
game day when you've already got the
plan involved taysom hill already has
his role for the game it's one thing to
say if drew gets injured we're making
jameis winston the quarterback because
taysom hill is still going to do taste
some health things and they've already
planned it and prepared it and practiced
it
if they know
this week
that drew can't go
is taysom hill the quarterback or is it
jameis winston and that's an important
question because last year
when drew brees missed five games with a
thumb injury teddy bridgewater was the
quarterback but teddy bridgewater was
always listed at number two last year
over taysom hill hill was three
bridgewater was two this year on the
unofficial depth chart i always like to
say it's unofficial because they don't
want anyone to take it seriously even
though they create it and they put it on
their website and they profit from all
the clicks that people generate by going
to see what the depth chart is taysom
hill is number two this year winston is
number three so it really does make me
wonder if you have a whole week to get a
game plan ready
you know you always want to put your
best guys on the field and all due
respect to jameis winston taysom hill's
a better quarterback right now than
jameis winston yeah i think well i don't
know what you think but i'd go with
taysom hill over jameis winston
it's it that's a tough one it is you
know because we haven't had us we've
never seen taysom hill play a full game
quarterback i don't really know i mean
the skill set is there to where i go i'm
with you mike i go it's special some of
the things he can do
you know but jameis winston you know
let's not forget and i know we've heard
this from coaches you know in in you
know our nfl world he does some special
damn things too now he's done some
special dumb things as well as far as
interceptions in that but i i i don't
know mike where you go here you know i
would like to you know what we saw last
year too is when teddy bridgewater came
in
it took the taysom hill part of the
offense away too because now he had to
become the backup quarterback and they
were scared to let him run quarterback
design runs or do things like that to
where yeah bridgewater got hurt now we
don't have another quarterback so i
would think they follow the same formula
letting jameis winston be the guy and he
be the backup but i i don't know i don't
know what what their thought will be
here
one more thing before we take a break
and this relates to bridgewater who was
the backup last year and now is the
starter in carolina they took him for an
mri last night on a right knee injury
not the knee that was devastated in 2016
but he took a low hit it didn't look
good
um
and and usually the mris the next day i
thought it was odd that they did the mri
last night and here's what's even more
odd
crickets
regarding the results of the mri yeah
it's a little weird
and i look at how matt rule has handled
things so far he understands the
strategic value of silence like
christian mccaffrey he's day to day and
then he misses the game this week and
after the game rules said he didn't have
any update on teddy bridgewater i think
they understand to say as little as
possible because you know if they're
going to be out there maybe trying to
negotiate with some free agent
quarterback i don't know who's even
available right now but whatever move
you're going to try to make
if if no one knows how desperate you are
to get another quarterback on the roster
then the negotiation goes more smoothly
for your interest so it just makes me
wonder
the fact that we haven't heard
all is well we heard ahead of time they
don't think it's any big deal okay fine
why are you doing the mri tonight then
and why haven't we heard anything about
the results of the mri so this is one of
those 20 years of doing this
you've seen everything multiple times
over this is one where i'm kind of like
hmm
something's going on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports